he tubers is Charlie Happy Thanksgiving
Kevin Feige was recently talking about
the state of comic book filmmaking
Marvel vs. DC so wanted to make a video
about that but they actually like Marvel
and DC characters literally fought each
other in the amalgam universe so I'll
explain that too so here we go this
doesn't have to end in a fight Tony you
just started a war
time you learned what it means to be a
man
I wanted it you be dead already
she would you I thought yours with you
have you do this all day
underoos everyone so let start with the
fun stuff first open pitch battle
between Marvel and DC characters in the
amalgam universe if you never heard of
it it was a limited series in the mid
90s where DC and Marvel wrote a story
that was like out of the main continuity
where the characters from the different
companies learned of each other's
existence and then fought this battle
the losers universe would die off so
like if the Marvel characters won Mortal
Kombat style
DC's universe would be killed off but it
was out of continuity so it was just a
fun way to say this isn't really
happening in spoil earning for the end
of that story I'll just wait a second or
if you guys want to like skip forward in
the video like 30 seconds so what ends
up happening is is it becomes this
situation whereby they combine the two
universes despite Marvel characters
having won the battle but there's like a
big twist whereby they allow the two
universes to be fused it becomes the
amalgam universe with you know both
Marvel and DC characters in it but the
actual battles that they fought were
Aquaman versus Namor Elektra versus
Catwoman flash versus Quicksilver Robin
versus Jubilee Silver Surfer vs. Green
Lantern Thor versus Captain Marvel
Superman versus the Hulk spider-man
versus Superboy Batman versus Captain
America Wolverine versus Lobo and storm
versus Wonder Woman so like when you see
Superman holding Thor's hammer and
Captain America shield going on and on
about how amazing it feels that's from
the amalgam comics but as for whether
they would ever do that in the movies I
don't think there's ever a chance for
that maybe they might make an animated
movie but that seems like a long shot
there's always lots of jokes and
references that Marvel makes the DC
characters in its titles DC does the
same thing with Marvel characters I
think it's just going to stay at that
level for the time being
but I totally think it's possible they
could revisit this idea in some like
alternate form of media even if they
can't do it in the live-action films but
the ongoing debate Marvel vs. DC has
largely just been a comic book thing you
know thanks to the efforts of Stan Lee
and the people at DC in the past 40 to
50 years so as was the case then you
know typically the people at the top
like Stan Lee like Kevin Feige nowadays
which is you know mostly my reason for
making this video we're really cool with
the competition despite it being very
friendly it's like a football match you
want your team to win but that doesn't
mean that you hate the other team so
maybe this is a surprise to you maybe
it's not a surprise but Kevin Feige said
that he's a fan of all superhero films
like all studios who are adapting from
what he says the comic book medium so
that includes like Fox that includes the
Sony people but obviously they've
already made the arrangement for
spider-man but you know Kevin Feige just
seems like a really cool dude who really
loves comic books and really loves to
make movies so there isn't like an ounce
of hate inside his heart for any of his
supposed competitors certainly each
comic book studio has its own criticisms
Marvel and DC are just like the two big
ones just because of the IP that they
control you know Fox x-men universe is
still really big - but comparatively
there's fewer movies that they could
make but even though they share some of
the same issues as DC's films the
criticisms are actually very very
different like when you look back at the
old Marvel films a lot of them almost
look like TV shows just because of the
way they filmed them they've largely
tried to change that but they've had
phase 1 phase 2 phase 3 they've had a
lot of movies to kind of tweak the way
they make their films look so because DC
chose to start its film universe the DC
EU with Zack Snyder and probably his
biggest skill is his visual style like
the DC movies that we've seen so far
look amazing but the problem is is
there's like a billion different things
that make a really good film so even if
it looks amazing that doesn't
necessarily guarantee that it's going to
be an amazing experience and really I
think that's the most important thing is
like what you feel like when the movies
over
I think in each case like marvel even
like the x-men films and DC films are
all really fun to watch but the problem
is is that there are certain films in
each of their libraries that just like
aren't really fun to re-watch again and
again so really the mark of a really
good comic book film is something that
you can rewatch like a billion times
like when I was a little kid
I was able to rewatch the Star Wars
films over and over because they were
pretty good films with a pretty good
story and they visually looked really
interesting at least for the time I mean
obviously film has evolved a lot since
the original Star Wars movies have been
made 2016 in particular has been a
really hard year for comic book films
just because of what's going on in the
world what's happening in the United
States so you know people just get
angrier and angrier so you look to films
like these to make you feel better about
existence and life so when you see a
film with a really dark tone that
doesn't necessarily help so I think the
greatest crimes against comic book films
this year were mostly crimes of tone not
so much of story because there are
always story problems in comic book
films Captain America Civil War very fun
film to watch with a very hopeful twist
at the end but it also has all kinds of
story problems along the way so you look
at a film like Deadpool that kind of
turns that on its head which is why I
think it did so well because it had just
the right tone for the right story for
the right character at the right time
and I think the answer to that like the
tone problem of this year and you know
where Deadpool got right in 2016
spider-man homecoming we'll get it right
in 2017 along with Justice League we can
talk about what happened to Superman at
the end of Batman V Superman and I think
most of us have a pretty good idea of
what's going to happen with his arc
during Justice League but you know maybe
some people haven't read the comics they
don't know the death of Superman arc
let's just say there's going to be some
really exciting stuff happening in
Justice League and don't forget there is
a Star Wars movie happening at the end
of the year there's like a very small
Star Wars Episode 8 movie very quiet
indie production so a lot of the
pessimism that you see in the fandom now
will largely be gone by the time that
gets here just because of the things
that are coming in 2017 in the fact that
the
Studios have seen like the way people
have reacted to all the movies that have
come out this year and said okay we're
gonna listen we understand you really
like these characters but you're not
super happy with the way they treated
them in these movies so Marvel vs. DC at
the box office
Marvel crushed it this year DC crushed
it this year too despite what people
thought about each of their films like
there were people that hated the Marvel
films this year there were people that
hated the DC films this year but they
still made billions of dollars all
around that is because one they have
really good marketing machines so
regardless of the quality of films
there'll always be people that will show
up for Ben Affleck Henry Cavill Robert
Downey jr. but the reason why you see
all kinds of movies make crazy money
even if they're not the greatest films
ever is because people love those
characters so they'll show up for their
movies it's just that there'll be a lot
of complaining after the fact like I
can't believe that movie was so terrible
but they'll still go see the next movie
with that character even if the previous
movie wasn't that great so the studio's
pick up on that they're like okay people
love Batman
people love Captain America we
understand you're not super satisfied
with the last movie we made we'll do
better next time
so they go back to the kitchen they
bring the meal out they try to make it
better
this actually played out pretty early on
with Marvel's films if you remember the
Incredible Hulk not the greatest film
ever but I think it's been long enough
the people largely give Marvel a pass
just because there been so many Marvel
films since then they've had enough time
to hit their stride they found the right
actors like they've started to land some
really big a-list talent like Cate
Blanchett is in a Thor movie that just
seems ridiculous and exciting but
ridiculous that she would sign on after
seeing the first two Thor movies but DC
has only just started like it took him a
long time to make Batman V Superman so
that you know the problem with making
films is that it'll take you a couple
years so you're making this huge bed so
you don't get feedback till the movie
drops they got their feedback now they
can go back and make a better film bring
it back
it's just that Marvel has been through
that grinder so many more times than DC
has so far the DC will get there Geoff
Johns is the new Kevin Feige there's a
comic book guy up at the
it's not gonna let them drag the
characters through the mud so it's just
gonna take a little while to make these
movies so you know that's why I think a
lot of people were disappointed this
year because it's like hey you know we
want a better movie and they're like
okay we'll make a better movie but it
just takes a couple years to get there
mark my words in like the next five
years what you're gonna see is you'll
see like the slate of Geoff Johns
pioneer DC films and there'll be a much
more equal consensus from Marvel quality
and DC quality so I think you know the
Marvel films that people will be really
satisfied with in the next couple years
will be spider-man homecoming Thor
Ragnarok black panther and both infinity
war films on the DC side I think those
films that people will be most happy
about after leaving the movie theater
will be Justice League the flash Aquaman
you can't you can't not like Jason Momoa
he is like one of the best actors that
they've ever landed and the Man of Steel
sequel the Superman films more than
anything our DC's opportunity to make
heartwarming films that are really
exciting that you could re watch a
billion times and you guys can let me
know in the comments like which Marvel
and which DC films do you think will be
the most rewatched in the next five
years you know we'll be like the flash
film will it be the Justice League film
infinity war they're like certain films
that are just so much more fun to watch
from Marvel and DC and I've already
rewatched most of the Marvel films so
many times that it started to be like a
song that you can't get out of your head
so I tend to appreciate the smaller ones
like ant-man Doctor Strange things that
do really weird different things which
is why I'm super excited about Thor
Ragnarok so it's a little bit easier to
rewatch stuff that you haven't already
seen a billion times which is why Kevin
Feige said that they're trying to do so
many different things in phase 3 and
phase 4 that they've never done before
which is the same from the other Studios
so like Kevin Feige said he's really
excited about the films his competitors
are making he's really excited about DC
films I think it's the same thing from
Geoff Johns and the DC people you know
most of the comic book guys that you run
into or actually really cool dudes there
are like a few mr. burns type people up
at the top at all the studios
but largely like they're getting pushed
out the door so like Kevin Feige was
able to take Marvel Studios off on their
own so they don't have to worry too much
about that the DC people made Geoff
Johns one of the new gods of their film
universe so there's just so much
exciting stuff happening that's gonna be
dropping next year literally next year
like you're not gonna have to wait that
long and I know there's a lot of rumors
about trailers for like Justice League
Spider Man dropping in the next couple
weeks so be sure to subscribe to get
everything I will be doing a spider-man
homecoming carnage video later tonight
so that'll post in a couple hours but if
there are any comic book bonus videos
that you guys want me to do or movie
bonus videos this weekend just let me
know in the comments what you guys wait
for that to post you can click here to
watch that funny spider-man Tom Holland
video where he gets that special Batman
surprise and you can click here to watch
like the latest arrow flash big four
night crossover trailer thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
you